je pense que là ça doit se jouer sur une
gauche qui ne transige pas avec ses
valeurs d'égalité réelle de qui transige
pas sur des objectifs par exemple d'un
emploi digne pour toutes et tous et ne
transige pas avec la valeur travail et
ne transige pas avec le pro le besoin de
changer profondément les façons de
produire et de consommer face au
changement climatique
et je le dis par exemple sur le débat
sur le nucléaire puisque depuis hier
soir quand même ça à la question du
nucléaire pour moi est un marqueur aussi
c'est à dire que quand on considère que
le nucléaire pourrait être un outil pour
pour répondre aux changements
climatiques c'est un réel problème y
compris du point session c'est une
énergie décarbonée donc ils sont
réalistes les lectrices je rappelle
quand même que l'électricité c'est 5 %
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
donc des gaz à effet serre c'est pas ça
qui fera de toutes les limites et tous
les dangers nucléaires c'est pas ça qui
va répondre au problème c'est un autre
débat bah oui mais bah oui mais pour moi
la gauche c'est ça aussi c'est de rester
c'est aussi de d'être clair sur sur ce
type de débat là on ne répond pas
aujourd'hui au changement climatique par
des fausses solutions de marché du team
marché carbone ou neutralité carbone
autant qu'on aurait pour qu'on n'y
répond pas par des fausses solutions
technologiques qui par ailleurs engendre
d'autres risques et donc il faut être à
la fois droits sur les questions
écologiques sur les questions sociales
et sur les questions de libertés
publiques est ce pour ça que moi
j'appelle un bloc arc en ciel qui est je
finirai là dessus le rouge des
traditions communiste syndical le vert
dès de l'écologie le jeune des
insurrections populaires le feu le
violet du féminisme et multicolore de
l'antiracisme parce que il faut
reprendre quelque part les
revendications de chacune de ces luttes
et leur radicalité mais aussi au sens de
remise en cause des racines du système
pour répondre réellement aux
préoccupations des citoyennes et des
citoyens
[Musique]